most people's lives are there's a life
Arc
and most people's lives transpire in
like ways that you could see over and
over again you know so I I break it down
it seems to me like there are there are
three big phases in life
the first phase is you're dependent on
others and you're learning
of usually your parents
uh then you go out on your own others
become dependent on you and you're
working you're trying to be successful
and almost every year practically not
not every year but in neighborhoods of
years you're this age you get married at
this age or you get to your life partner
and be at that age they said you have
kids when you have kids uh your parents
are now entering their third phase
and so there are those things that we
all know so I put in that life Arc you
know a checklist what happens in the
first
uh you know when do you first
um have a romance when do you first and
you could see the list and there's a
checklist and when you go through the
checklist you can check off how many of
the things happen to you wherever and
you can see right where you are and
because by looking at that checklist you
could also see what's coming next
and you could see a by and large not
only what's coming next to you but if
you look at it over let's say what are
the net things I can expect over the
next 10 years as as likely and then you
could do that for your loved ones what
does that mean for your parents where
will they be over the next 10 years
where will your what about your children
and what about your friends and what are
these phases in your life like and how
should you approach that so by having
them in that perspective you can step
back and you can you can put that in
perspective and you can you know learn
and think about okay there's the next 10
years